oggi i ragazzi sono più fatto del solito
ma chi se ne frega l'importante è che
l'audio si sa che c questa cosa hanno
non mi abituerò mai a questa cosa del
canale tropea è troppo anche per me
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fra i j e oggi
trattiamo un altro argomentino molto
carino mi fa piacere come sempre che gli
argomenti scorsi li abbiano interessato
così tanto parlo delle dipingervi la
moda delle viuzze di soldi tutto figo di
rispondo sotto nei commenti molto spesso
con questa questo dibattito che creiamo
ogni volta vidi posto su instagram
insomma da quando c'è questo dialogo
sono molto più ispirato perché scambiare
quattro chiacchiere su vari argomenti è
una cosa che mi interessa fare in questo
periodo
è mista volto piacendo quindi nice
parliamo quindi ragazzi di un altro
argomento che mi sta molto a cuore
diciamo più che altro perché molta gente
non sa e quindi quando la gente non sa
il favi interviene non voglio passare
assolutamente per alberto angela per
quanto mi farebbe un sacco piacere però
cosa significa essere famosi pro e
contro ma io vi parlerò soprattutto dei
contro perché sono fatto così perché io
parlare le cose però non mi piace però
per essere corretti mi sembra giusto
parlare sia dei pro e dei contro quindi
partiamo prima con i propri
i soldi
bene ora che mi hanno portato nei pro
parliamo dei contro io sono diventato
per così dire fatto per quanto io non
abbia mai utilizzato il termine è famoso
perché proprio non mi piace non mi piace
proprio neanche esserlo figuriamoci dire
proprio la parola famoso non mi piace
però parliamo di questo e ho iniziato ad
acquisire popolarità nel
2013 prima quando iniziato a fare video
ho iniziato ad essere fermato per strada
anche prima mi fermavano durante il
primo anno ma in modo molto più
ricorrente soprattutto il fatto che ho
iniziato a capire
che se io avessi incrociato lo sguardo
di qualsiasi ragazzo dai dagli otto ai
bambini dagli 8 ai ragazzi di 18 anni ai
tempi più o meno quella persona mi
avrebbe al 90 per cento riconosciuto
quindi quello è stato il momento in cui
mi sono reso conto di essere famoso ok
perché le prime volte in cui mi hanno
riconosciuto agli eventi al al torino
comics mi ricordo i primi eventi che ho
fatto è stato il torino comics
erano in quattro ad aspettarmi
all'entrata del torino comics i primi
quattro fan che viene riconosciuto in
giro
e stato un bellissimo momento però
quello essere riconosciuti
sporadicamente e se le famose significa
non poter uscire
non poter riuscire a no vabbè significa
uscire
sapendo che comunque nel tuo tragitto
dovunque tu stia andando in italia
ovviamente a meno che tu non sia famoso
nel mondo
qualsiasi tragitto tu farai tu sai che
qualcuno ti riconoscerà quello significa
essere famosi
dipende come la si prende come cosa
dipende dal vostro carattere ecco nel
mio caso è un po
non me la sono vissuto benissimo eco
mettiamola così facciamo un attimo di
chiarezza iniziato a fare video su
youtube perché mi divertivano i
videogiochi mi divertono tutoria
videogiochi e volevo condividere con voi
questa passione ok mai mi sarei
aspettato un exploit del genere a
saperlo l'avrei fatto lo stesso sì
perché ovviamente mi ha cambiato la vita
sono migliorato come persona ora riesco
a tenere un dialogo con la persona in
giro senza abbassare lo sguardo per la
timidezza quindi insomma anche a livello
caratteriale mi ha formato proprio
questo lavoro è stato proprio bello io
sono contentissimo di fare lo youtube e
re sono contento di aver avuto questo
successo quindi mettiamo le cose dove
stanno e non diciamo cagate però non è
tutto rosa e fiori ecco questo
sicuramente
perché appunto per una persona di indole
introversa come lo sono io essere
fermato per strada è bello ok ma non sul
momento sul momento nel mentre che sta
per succedere non lo è perché quando una
persona si approccia a me per come sono
fatto io di carattere ma lascia stare
che sono pari j anche se uno mi si para
personale mi chiede un'indicazione ok
che io non la sua mai ma per non fare la
figura di merda gli dato lo stesso per
quello che sa dove va a finire arrivare
da un punto a a un punto b è complicato
un po come quando passi in pokémon in
mezzo all'erba alta quindi sai che prima
o poi qualcosa dice voi
dipende dal tuo mood attuale soprattutto
dipende dal tuo carattere non è
cattiveria
però quando mi fermo vi fermate mi fa
piacere in realtà non è quello però per
farvi capire che non è semplice
soprattutto se dovete fare qualcosa di
importante
quindi questo aspetto è negativo però lo
è dipende dal carattere nel mio caso che
me la vivo così è un è un po negativo da
buttare più sul negativo che sul
positivo ripeto mi fa piacere in realtà
è solo una questione caratteriale quello
non ci posso fare niente però
tranquilli se volete fare foto con me
non c'è problema parliamo invece di cose
che sono gravi oggettivamente perché
esistono chi invade la privacy ok allora
ghazi abito a milano da sette anni più o
meno sempre stato in affitto per una
questione proprio del fatto che io non
voglio vivere a milano per il resto
della mia vita non vivrò per sempre a
milano a meno che non incontrò la
persona giusta a milano e quindi rimarrò
qua per una questione proprio di di
amore è in tutte le case in cui ho
vissuto c'è sempre stata gente che mi sa
che mi è venuta a citofonare in casa
ecco questo è un questo è un problema
oggettivo
mi ricordo che tempo fa ho sentito un
discorso di forse gabbo non mi ricordo
chi forse humans affari anche un po
tutti va bene hanno fatto suo discorso
qua
avevo visto i loro video in particolare
dove dicevano non venite a citofonare mi
sotto casa perché io poi la foto con voi
non belle non me la faccio e non vi
saluto e la gente sotto indignata nei
commenti scriveva tipo è ma che c'entra
sono fan sui lavori grazie all'oro
centra una sega questo ragazzi spero che
voi lo sappiate le persone me compreso
diventano famosi grazie al pubblico e ci
mancherebbe quindi per strada per quanto
io sia di indole
introverso mi fermo sempre e chiacchiero
ci mancherebbe però in generale il fatto
di fermarsi sotto casa e citofonare è un
problema grave di privacy cioè se uno
non può stare più tranquillo manco in
casa è finita perché poi tu cosa fai vai
a fare la foto con loro gli diceva date
ragazzi la faccio ma non dite a nessuno
che abito qua quello lì che ovviamente è
venuto a citofonare a casa non sarà mai
uno grande perché se sei grande e
capisci che un problema se sei piccolo
non lo capisci non è che sei stupido sei
solo piccolo poi da grande di fringe rai
alla vita per averlo fatto cioè tu hai
di dai dai 16 18 anni in poi da quando
ti si generano i neuroni in grado di
analizzare il problema è capire che è un
problema non dormirei più la notte per
sapendo quello che hai fatto e mi chiama
che cazzo suonato a rompere le palle
l'iva però una persona non non scende
per fare una foto perché sennò la
arrivano un miliardo di altre persone ma
a prescindere da quella è proprio il
concetto è sbagliato in casa si è in
casa punto cioè non esiste più privacy a
quel punto ma va c'è di cosa stiamo
parlando quindi questo è un problema
molto molto molto grave quindi ragazzi
da bravi non andate a citofonare la
gente questo lo dico in generale ma
chiunque sia perché è un grosso problema
e non è che la gente cattiva non vuole
fare la foto con voice è andata a
citofonare e che non si fa questo non si
fa proprio cioè sbagliata cioè io
non so neanche come cacchio sia
possibile però lo capisco che uno che
uno piccolo non lo capisca perché anche
io ero così ero non sono mai andata a
casa di nessuno io però mi ricordo che i
tempi quando ero un fan sfegatato di più
di paio mi ricordo questa cosa avevo
quel mezzo pensiero di prendere il treno
e andarlo a beccare c'è tipo dove stava
anche se non avevo idea cioè nel senso
volevo girare per vicenza visto che è
marzo era di vicenza giusto per avere la
possibilità di incontrarlo che questa è
una cosa che non ho mai fatto e con il
senno di poi ho detto meno male che non
l'ho mai fatto che minchiata assurda è
però me ne sono reso conto col tempo
perché sono maturato anche io e ho
capito che è una cosa sbagliata questa è
la parte che parla di più della privacy
di essere riconosciuti in giro altri
discorsi altrettanti importanti
potrebbero essere sempre riguardanti la
privacy il fatto che se tu magari non so
banalmente se tutti ti fidanzi con
qualcuno poi lo sanno tutti poi se vi
lasciate continua a stupire ma vi siete
lasciati
sotto i commenti le foto di entrambi
mettono delle foto insieme
fan page scrivono a sean lascia
spesso problemi un po più da gossip però
comunque sono problemi e tra l'altro ma
io tra l'altro in un immagino neanche
perché comunque a livello web è
difficile che tutto finisca su sui
magazine dei gossip grazie a dio è per
me grazie a dio però per quelli che sono
famosi in televisione dove appunto i
boomers i vanno a comprare le riviste di
gossip deve essere ancora peggio perché
tu hai proprio su carta stampata la tua
faccia con su scritto a la ragazza l'ha
tradito cioè non puoi neanche neanche te
lo puoi tenere per te come cosa e girati
le palle durante tutta la giornata da
solo no lo devono sapere pure tutti è
orribile o rid cioè deve essere una roba
guarda non voglio anche pensarci una
cosa devastante l'ultima cosa
andiamo avanti per anni che non
non mi va a genio della della fama e il
fatto di non poter sbagliare come gli
altri vi faccio un esempio io ho
sofferto di depressione per un po lo
sapete perché sono usciti quegli
articoli proprio perché essendo così
tanto sotto i riflettori avevo paura di
fare tutto qualsiasi cosa io ho paura di
fare qualsiasi cosa perché vado a
buttare una bottiglia di plastica nel
cestino sbaglio il cestino qualcuno mi
fa la foto la vj fa male la raccolta
differenziata e bastardo ci fosse lì
capito che non è tanto il concetto delle
tic perché di quella non me ne frega
niente come sapete tutti uno può pensare
quello che vuole però comunque il fatto
di non poter sbagliare liberamente
è un problema c'è nel senso
tu devi stare più attento degli altri
negli sbagli perché tu puoi sbagliare se
gli esseri umani sbagliano ma adesso
lasciamo cioè parlo in generale
dio non solo passo col rosso
butto la bottiglia nel cestino sbagliato
insomma gli sbagli si fanno l'importante
è capire lo sbaglio e correggersi questo
sempre se sei una persona normale sia
una persona famosa è la stessa cosa con
il fatto che però tutti parlano di
questo sbaglio io ho dovuto esser bravo
a cercare di convincermi alla fine mi
sono convinto e sono molto tranquillo
oggi che se sbaglio io vale come uno
sbaglio di un altro cioè sono un essere
umano due gambe e due braccia un
cervello come tutti sono essere umano
posso sbagliare adesso non mi mettere
anche come però potrebbe succedere e fa
niente nel senso
tutti sbagliano ok
però so lo so di per certo perché uno
l'ho vissuto sulla mia pelle 2 lo so
perché parlando insomma con varie altre
creato so che comunque questa cosa devo
sbagliare e vissuta male nel senso che
ognuno ha paura di esporsi
siano tante paure per paura della
reazione mediatico ok cosa che io adesso
non ho però mi rendo conto che questo è
un grosso problema e lo è stato anche
per me non è facile ok per tante cose ci
sono i lati positivi e ireland i
negativi si potrebbe parlare di sta roba
per anni in realtà perché gli argomenti
sono mille però vi ho parlato delle
principali problematiche se non ci
fossero queste diciamo che sarebbe
veramente una pacchia fare questa cosa
qua poi ci sarebbero altre cose tipo
magari se litigato con la ragazza in
video non lo puoi far vedere che sei
triste perché sono video c'è una cagata
quindi devi essere sempre felice non è
facile fare il creatore ci sono tante
cose uno pensa che sia facile ma realtà
non è proprio così quindi ci sarebbero
tanti argomenti da aprile però per farvi
capire comunque non è tutto rose e fiori
come si pensa assolutamente i ragazzi
concludo quel video di oggi spero che vi
sia piaciuto fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate
e come al momento mi piace iscrivetevi
al canale decidiamo come sempre ad un
prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]